اكدت منظمه الصحه العالميه ان نقص المياه
في المناطق المتضرره من الزلزال يزيد
مخاطر تفشي الامراض الماضيه وقال ممثل
المنظمه في تركيا ان المنظمه تعمل مع
السلطات المحليه على مراقبه الامراض
المعديه التي تنتقل بين النازحين عن طريق
المياه اضافه الى الانفلونزا وكوفيد اثر
الضرر الكبير الذي لحق بشبكات المياه
والصرف الصحي في المناطق المتضرره
معنى من غازي عنتاب مراسل الجزيره منتصر
ابو نبوت منتصر كيف تبدو الاوضاع في غزه
عنتاب والى اي مدى يقلق موضوع امكانيه
تفشي الامراض والاوبئه يقلق السلطات
المحليه هناك
حسن يعني الوضع في غازي عنتاب يعني هذه
المدينه بدات تستعيد شيئا من ملامح الحياه
خلال اليومين الماضيين وحتى خلال هذا
اليوم السلطات تركز جهودها على اعاده
الحياه الى المناطق المنكوبه وطمانه الناس
وتقديم المساعدات واعاده البناء التحتيه
الاساسيه بما فيها قضيه الاوبئه وقد
شاهدنا خلال يعني اليومين الماضيين وجود
اشخاص يقومون بعمليات رش المبيدات تخوفا
من هذه الاوبئه وايضا شاهدنا عمليات لقاح
تعطى للاطفال من قبل الهلال الاحمر وذلك
كل ذلك في اطار
المناعه التي يريد ان يكسبوها للناس خوفا
من تفشي الامراض وايضا يعني تدارك لاي
كارثه اخرى قد تحصل بسبب هذه الاوبئه وهي
بسبب حقيقه تحلل بعض الجثث تحت الانقاض
وايضا بسبب اختلاط مياه الصرف الصحي
مياه
بمياه الشرب والمياه وقت المياه هي وقد
عادت الى اغلب مناطق ولايه غازي عنتاب فقد
اكدت في الولايه ان هذه المياه حتى هذه
اللحظه غير صالحه للشرب هي فقط للغسول
والاستحمام وغير ذلك لكنها غير صالحه
للشرب واكدت هذا الامر للمواطنين السلطات
تعمل على اعاده الغاز حاليا وقد يعني صرحت
ولايه غازي عنتاب بان قبل نهايه الاسبوع
سيتم اعاده الغاز الى جميع المناطق التي
قطعت عنها كل هذه الجهود تاتي في ظل
استمرار عمليه رفع الانقاذ انتهت العمليه
رفع الانقاذ في معده مواقع وفي عده مدن من
الولايات غازي عنتاب لكن هناك بعض المواقع
لا تزال الاعمال الجاريه بالنسبه لفرق
الانقاذ لرفع الانقاذ قضيه خروج اشخاص
ناجين من تحت الانقاذ لم تعد قضيه سهله
بصيص الامل اصبح ضعيفا بعد كل هذه المده
ايضا شاهدنا عمل اعمال لسلطات المحليه
بتحسين الطرقات الجراح هذا الزلزال وتقوم
بتعبيد هذه الطرقات خصوصا الطرقات المؤديه
الى المناطق الريفيه ايضا هنالك حاليا
تجري في هذا الوقت عمليه بناء بيوت متنقله
بالقرب من مدينتي نورداغ والاصلاحيه وذلك
لواء اكثر من 30 الف شخص سيتم استقبالهم
في هذه البيوت المتنقله لفتره وجيزه وكما
يعني هو معلوم مدينتين والاصلاحيه سيتم
هدمهما بشكل كامل واعاده بناءهما من جديد
بسبب الدمار الكبير الذي حل بهما شكرا لك
من غازي عنتاب منتصر ابو النبوت